[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by eduardo franco
aka argyle and stranger things season
four volume one we're talking spoilers
about what we've seen so far so make
sure you watch volume one first and then
come back to this interview eduardo how
you doing today man
good man
dude it's
it's so good to see you i'm like just
you know how great your character is and
you just kill it and for this part
though of argyle did you have to
audition for this part or was it
something that was kind of written for
you
oh man uh well thank you man i
appreciate it i'm glad i'm glad uh he
resonates with you you know i'm glad
you're [ __ ] with me um
oh i i did audition uh several times for
uh the show at first i read for like
another part
um for this season four
and uh
and then um
and then i i remember i had to read for
like a stoner guy
and uh
then when i finally got the part that's
when yeah that's when i i found out uh
uh finn had actually um
had me in mind he had gotten the scripts
like ahead of time
and he uh he had asked like the duffers
and like and like sean uh he had asked
him like hey
uh do you guys have someone for argyle
yet
and uh and they were like we're working
on it and he was like there's this guy
uh in this movie called book smart and
he was like he should get you should get
that guy his name is eduardo
and and uh
this was like before i'd even met
finn or anything we didn't know each
other or anything it was so sick like
when i found out about that
i got everything in the park or whatever
then i went to do the
the
the table read in atlanta and that's
where i met finn and stuff and then
chatting up with him and and uh sean
sean came over was like do you hear what
did different tell you already and phil
was like no no don't worry about it and
like sean like basically like spill the
beans or whatever like that finn had
like basically put in like a little
you know planted a seed too like they
were like already like they told they
told me that they were like already sort
of looking at me but like finn like also
had suggested so like it almost i don't
know it's so great like i i [ __ ] i
love finn so much like i appreciate him
for that like
he totally did not need to do that and
it was it was crazy like
i don't know it's just mind-blowing
dude that's amazing that's like just
surreal to hear that finn hooked up like
that's awesome and what a great choice
by him looking out for you now
eduardo he didn't know he didn't owe me
anything like he didn't even know me or
anything he just that was that just came
out of him like
nah man i'm super grateful and
appreciative for that like seriously
yeah that's that's awesome that's
awesome there's such a good attitude
about it now
eduardo was it a sigh of relief for you
to see
the critics and fans loving this season
like did you kind of feel weight off
your shoulders being a new character
um
was it a sigh of relief
to see uh sorry the you said can you
word that again real quick oh no yeah
was it a sign of relief to see like
critics and fans loving this new season
like did you feel like kind of a weight
off your shoulder with that
ah it's you know dude it's like uh
um
i hope people are loving it you know
like uh it is there's that big pressure
of like i'm joining
uh this this cast and this crew
that is sort of like it's like a family
now and they've been in it since the
beginning and and their beginning wasn't
what they expected i mean nobody
expected it to get this big
so the pressures is monumental but um
uh i'm just like so thankful that like
everybody in the casting crew has been
so cool and so welcoming
and and like you know when they they you
know the duffers and and and everybody
they all know like exactly what it is to
like
uh uh uh bring you know to the table and
like to just be able to be a part of
that
and and and and know that like you know
um
that uh that i was that i was you know i
was uh given an opportunity and and it
was all like
in in good favor and like everybody was
so welcoming and stuff like now whatever
you know whatever people
perceive it as is like
you know well i'm kind of like well
we'll see you know but i i mean it's
good to hear that you know it's doing
well i'm glad of i'm really like
grateful about that that's amazing that
like you know that people do enjoy it
and
especially like yeah because my
character's new you know it's almost
like who is that guy you know what are
you trying to bring what are you what
are you doing here it's like like the
new kid in the at the at the lunch table
like
what are you capable of what are you
trying to get to you know what's your
purpose here like
so i i you know if if it's if it is you
know resonating making you fun like you
know laugh or something giving you some
sort of like
distraction from all the madness well
i'm i'm glad i really am like i'm
relieved if anything
yeah man i i even had friends watching
and texting me like i love this
character of argyle he's awesome so you
really delivered and it's it's great
that like you can contribute to this
awesome season now
did you find a lot of
eduardo
a lot of eduardo in argyle like did you
relate a lot to the character in any
ways i think yeah i think so i think
kind of but um uh
and there's always like that you know
with the characters always like a part
of you that is in it that you're like
obviously like that's how you i don't
know everybody
as an individual person when they're
playing something there's a part of them
that goes into them that's like
sort of the comfort thing of it
but um
i think what it would be would be the
fact that uh that uh argyle was
completely oblivious
to anything you know like he was he's
he's obviously new to the whole thing
like
the family the buyers and and and mike
and them like they've they've been
through so much they've seen it all and
like this is argyle experiencing
everything for the first time so i guess
there's that parallel with me
experiencing
stranger things and stuff for like the
first time so it's it was uh i guess it
would be that yeah like i was
trying to approach it like that too like
i'm the i'm the only guy here despite
how
you know how blown out of my mind i am
i'm the only one with my head screwed on
tight because it's like everyone else is
like it's not that big of a deal and i'm
like what are you talking about this is
insane like yeah
yeah we're going who's insane yeah
i love that and you mentioned the buyers
too and like being around these people
and i think what a big relationship
people love is this like best bud
relationship with jonathan so
did you and charlie hit it off right
away was that kind of easy to kind of
get into that chemistry between you guys
yeah it was it was dude charlie man he's
so awesome and it was like it was so
organic and natural like we didn't have
to force anything we just
we uh
we just you know we just started talking
chatting it up and me and charlie are
also both the same age
so that that i maybe that helps you know
that we both grew up and sort of despite
him growing up obviously out in like
in in in london and stuff and and i grew
up over here in in
in arizona like it's just obviously two
completely different places
but uh he's such a he's such a funny
dude and like i know like obviously in
the show you don't really get to see
that stuff normally like before the
season but like
and it was so fun playing around with
them goofing off with them going off the
script a little bit a couple times and
like
uh
offset i mean we were just like hanging
out
playing video games all day we were i
took my nintendo
uh my nintendo 64 and we were playing uh
pokemon stadium and hell yeah looking at
each other the whole time it was so fun
yeah
yeah and it's cool you mentioned stuff
even like pokemon stadium what i love
about just your instagram account is you
share a lot of cool like figurines and
stuff and that you like embrace pop
culture and love things like that so are
you now seeing figurines coming out of
argyle that's you you know like the
funko mystery mini and there's
definitely gonna be a regular funko soon
is that mean more to you for someone who
actually gets why people appreciate
those tokens so much it's dude yeah i'm
i am i am uh
i am i am a crackhead when it comes to
when it comes to collectibles and
and and and toys and and video games and
[ __ ] like that man i i it's so it's so
bad it's like it's it's literally and it
just never stops there's never a feel
like i'm never
like
uh
seeing
stuff like memorabilia or whatever
that's like
like uh i don't know like collectibles
with me my character on it that's me or
whatever that stuff's that's like
surreal man it's so crazy to see like
um we found there's like a little
portable like bluetooth speaker
that's got the argyle like
like hair and the visor wow it's like a
little round little speaker and i was
like dude that's so first of all why but
also like
you know that so that's like awesome i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna fight it i'm
gonna like of course i'm embrace it it's
amazing that and like
um yeah like there's those mystery box
things that you were telling dude my
friends
my friends went crazy man like they went
crazy they saw those at the store and
they bought the whole thing oh wow like
the whole like shelf of it because
they're trying to get my character and i
was like
dude how much is each one individual and
they're like 18 dollars i was like yo
you're blue [ __ ] so much this little
this little plastic toy and
like the best part was they opened all
of them and they did not get my
character so oh man that was so funny
that's how they that's how they hook you
man it's it's like
it's crazy
no but that that's cool they have cool
friends like that too that will will get
your figure for you even though maybe
wasn't successful they're trying and
what's really cool too is
i think more people to know is that when
i was just doing research for this
interview how amazing of a rapper you
are and you have this legit rap band um
can you tell us more about that and do
you
love rapping as much as maybe you do
acting
dude it all it again like i
a lot of stuff that's been happening has
been like very organic you know it's
like uh
the the music man that's dial it all to
my my boy my my best bud uh uh nixon uh
dude he he's the other dumb [ __ ] in in
uh dumb [ __ ] within it
he uh he you know me and him we went to
high school together and uh
we became really good friends and then
uh he came out here later uh to pursue
the music stuff and like i was out here
trying to do the acting stuff and
and so like just hanging out like every
single day you know
on and off with like day jobs you know
sort of unemployed you know goofing off
like whenever he'd be you know
in the stew like making you know beats
and i'm trying to make his music i i
would i'd be sitting there too and then
i'd start saying like man let's get
let's do it let's get on the mic or
whatever let's you know like and it's so
it always it was always like just like
just vulgar [ __ ] just saying
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that was literally our
like that was like our tagline
like is we say [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot and so
it's always been that like fun stuff and
like uh it's slow it just like
organically turned into like oh we
should like take it serious and that was
that was crazy that was thanks to um
this dude uh this director tony yosenda
he directed american vandal
he uh after i'd gotten that part he
bugged me when he was like editing he
bugged me uh one day he he like texted
me he's like hey i heard your music and
and it was this like
cheeseburger song that we made about
eating cheeseburgers and he was like
yo he's like i want to get it in the
show and and i was like oh that was like
a goof around like that was like we
we ripped the beat off of like youtube
like that was like a joke and he was
like no no no i really like it and i was
like oh [ __ ] well i was like well we
don't really like own it or anything
he's like it's all good man he's like i
was just gonna see if we could even put
it in there he's like chances are we
wouldn't be able to but he was like
also he was like i love it by the way
keep doing it so then
you know after that we were like okay
well somebody somebody wasn't like
within our friend group within our
circle [ __ ] with it then like let's
try to
you know right we should probably give a
[ __ ] you know and so like
it's like just turned into like this
like fun
fun passion that we're like slowly
building up and you know eventually
we're gonna
you know plan on i don't know tour in
the [ __ ] world with it man it'd be
the best
hell yeah uh it's awesome and i hope
everyone let's you know check out his
band it's it's really cool for watching
this interview and um [ __ ] with
internet yeah hell yeah and uh they can
catch on youtube spotify the the whole
rounds right yeah yeah the whole thing
we're all out there man awesome and then
uh before i let you go i have to ask
again no spoilers but can you maybe give
us like a little tease for argyle like
where you know we might see a story go
for part two like anything you kind of
say like an adjective even
i i wish i know i wish man i don't know
if yeah i don't think
yeah i literally i legally cannot change
okay okay
i'm gonna guess so i'm gonna guess
behind me man they will find me yeah
they'll come for you somehow kevin feige
will come through even though he's not
involved
netflix actually has a vector on a leash
and they oh
they will unleash him on me so like if i
say something
i love that answer though that's great
um well eduardo it's been a treat
talking to you today and everybody
obviously
just keep watching stranger things
season four part one for now he is
amazing in it as argyle eduardo i hope
to talk to you in the future one day and
have a great day thank you for joining
me thank you my man you take care now